[Music]
hey guys we are so excited to announce
we are producing our own original
content head over to the trendy for the
best DIYs fashion tips makeup acts and
so much more we are sure you're going to
love it and be sure to let us know what
you think in the comment section here
from you descendants was probably the
best TV movie Disney ever made as we got
the chance to see the child of our
favorite princesses and villains in a
new adventure but unless you watch it
too many times just like we did you
probably miss many Disney connections
just wait until you find out what song
was playing when uma danced with Ben Ola
did you hear about our latest addition
to our family their richest espagnole is
the perfect place for all you native
Spanish speakers out there don't speak
Spanish no problem
come on over this is the perfect place
to practice amazing facts interesting
people and funny pictures those ammos
ahi today we are showing you 10 Disney
connections in descendants - that will
make your jaw drop the parents this is
the most obvious connection to Disney
movies that we all love those who live
in Oregon are the sons and daughters of
our favorite Disney Princesses and those
who live on the Isle of the Lost are the
children of the worst villains who ever
existed for example now is the daughter
of the terrifying Maleficent from
Sleeping Beauty just like her mother is
the villain that we fear the most mal is
also the leader of her group then we got
Evie the daughter of the Evil Queen from
Snow White and the Seven Dwarfs they
both care about their looks even if the
young woman can show that she has a
great personality too we also have Jay
who is Jafar son from Aladdin this time
he was not really like his father but
more like than nicest street urchin and
we won't forget Carlos Cruella de Vil
son from 101 Dalmatians who was
surprisingly afraid of dogs
then in auradon we got the chance to
meet then the new king and son of Belle
from Beauty and the Beast and then there
are all the other characters that we met
in the first and second movie who are
also the sons and daughters of our
favorite characters it's nice to see
that they are so similar that we could
understand where they came from but also
so different
we never knew what was coming in their
future the signs these first connections
were obvious but let's talk about
something that only the biggest disney
fans with an HDTV notice it is all the
signs on the Isle of the Lost
in the first and second movie you
obviously notice her slows fish and
chips and Lady Tremaine skirl up and die
but they were not the only ones who
started their own company and
descendants we could see that Gaston and
Froyo had villain shops they were right
there on the side of the screen when our
favorite villains were singing rotten to
the core as you can see the yellow sign
reads Gaston duels without rules and
another one reads Froyo scrappy reah
when we first met Edie we could also see
Captain Hook shop called hooks clock and
Curiosity Shop at least it looks like
this guy is not afraid of Crocs anymore
in the second movie we could see Shan
use dastardly dim-sum if you don't
remember him it was the guy from Mulan
then you can see Hades - Rocky
the Lord of the underworld from Hercules
and this one is just a bonus but we also
saw a sign reading feeling happy there
is help call the happiness prevention
hotline and we think that there are
probably many more things that we missed
in the background can you name one the
apples the second movie descendants -
started in the best way with the song
ways to be wicked this time our favorite
villains decided to use poisoned apples
to turn their schoolmates into bad
people just like them no one can resist
the temptation and as soon as they bit
this fruit they started dancing with mal
evj and Carlos you all know where this
fruit comes from this is how the Evil
Queen tried to get rid of the princess
and Snow White in the Seven Dwarfs and
the reason why we remember it so much is
because she was the first Disney
Princess but why are the apples making
people bad shouldn't they all be asleep
until a prince comes to save them
actually the princess biting an apple
represented a pure young girl who
couldn't resist the temptation and
become a sinner according to people who
study symbology the reason why she fell
in a deep sleep was that she needed to
wait and be old enough to find the true
love of her life and the
the fruit wouldn't be that bad anymore
you can also see the Apple in many
different fairytales in a fruit that
many people believe was an apple was
also mentioned in the Bible and we know
that bad things happen when you take a
bite of this fruit but the villains just
don't mind the classics the Apple is not
the only classic thing that we can
recognize from our favorite Disney
movies for example in the first movie
you could see that Maleficent had some
funny magnets on her fridge there was a
spinning wheel and her pet raven named
diablo you could also see blue and pink
magic flying out of the chimneys on the
Isle of the Lost
just like it happened in Sleeping Beauty
people also quickly saw the magic carpet
from Aladdin when Jay was singing in the
marketplace and a poster of his father
as the genie but that's not all we know
that our favorite Disney characters love
to have an animal companion and that is
exactly what happened when Carlos
adopted Duke the dog even started
talking in the second movie then we got
Jane the daughter of the fairy godmother
who loves pumpkin pie dozen that reminds
you of a magical carriage and her
ringtone is also the sound of her mom's
wand the story also repeats itself when
dizzy Drucilla's daughter had to do all
the chores and we will never forget when
Imai cast a spell on Ben just like her
mother did with Erik and when mal saved
her relationship with a kiss of true
love it is just proof that we can watch
these fairy tales again and again and we
will still love them even more the
dinner in dissonance - mal knew that she
was a terrible cook and this is why she
decided to use her spell book to prepare
something for her boyfriend then she
turned a simple sandwich into a
delicious meal and the king was really
impressed but did you really pay
attention to the food now made hors
d'oeuvres beef ragout and many other
things like that just like Lumiere did
when he wanted to impress Belle in be
our guests it just reminds us of the
remix of this song in the first movie
unfortunately it didn't end up well for
the couple they came quickly realized
that his girlfriend used magic to cook
all these things which means that she
lied to him and she was so is she
that she just ran away and decided to go
back to the Isle of the lost because she
didn't feel like she belongs in auradon
but isn't it weird to see that she
cooked the same thing as Lumiere with a
spell book
maybe that's because the funny
characters is Beauty and the Beast used
magic - and as long as they used it in a
good way
spell shouldn't always be a bad thing
right unfortunately we saw what happens
when a spell book fell into the wrong
hands
so now learns a good lesson that day she
won't use the spell book anymore and she
will have to learn how to make hors
d'oeuvres just like anyone else
the magic as we have seen during the
dinner mouth we'll use her spell book in
dissonance - it was a gift from her
mother Maleficent and even if she didn't
use it to do really bad things we can't
say that it was good either but she was
not the only one who used magic in the
first movie descendants Evie had a piece
of the magic mirror as a gift from her
mother the Evil Queen this is how she
got the answers to all her questions and
even impressed a teacher but she quickly
understood that she would be prouder of
using her own brain and this is why she
decided to give it away but the most
important thing in the first movie was
probably the fairy godmothers one that's
the reason why mal ebj and Carlos
decided to go to Oregon their parents
wanted them to seal it and even in the
second movie bloom a kid not been and
asked for the wand in exchange however
we all understood that the wand wasn't
as good as we thought in this new
adventure no one should have that much
power as magic cannot only be used for
the right reasons but also to do bad
things but we have to admit that we
would make the mistake of trying it at
least once before admitting that it was
a terrible idea the characters we love
to see new villains and good people in
dissonance but it was also fun to see
what happened with the characters that
we saw in the classic Disney movies
those that we saw the most rebel and the
beasts as they were Ben's parents they
are the proof that our favorite
characters really do live happily ever
after
even if life isn't always easy but then
we got the chance to see the famous
villains who never understood that doing
the wrong
would never make them happy it was great
to see Maleficent the Evil Queen Jafar
and Cruella De Vil in descendants but
they were not there anymore in the
second movie and this is why we want to
know what will happen to them in the
third movie and there were some other
famous characters in the film that you
probably didn't notice Audrey the
daughter of Sleeping Beauty was on
vacation with the fairies flora fauna
and Merryweather she even had a flat
tire in the Sherwood Forest we also got
the chance to see Ursula for a few
seconds and dissonance too however we
couldn't see the whole villain herself
but only a tentacle in her restaurant
and some fans also notice Lumiere in
human form in the second movie we can't
wait to see who is coming next if there
is a third movie the transformations
just when we thought that the kittens
too couldn't get better
we were captivated when uma and now
started fighting they weren't only
insulting each other
uma jumped in the water and turned into
an octopus just like her mother
Ursula then now transformed into a
dragon just like her mother Maleficent
used to do we even thought that then
would become a beast when he tried to
stop the fight if he was able to control
himself
this is all connected to the popular
Disney movies as the kids have the same
power as their parents however they
realized that it was a mistake to use it
this is why many people wonder why mal
turned into a dragon does that mean she
will never really be able to be good
actually it was just part of who she is
and that doesn't mean that it was bad
she was just doing this to protect Ben
and not to hurt anyone as the director
said there's something in her DNA that
enables her to become a large protective
version of herself as opposed to just
turning into a dragon to battle or to
hurt someone so we're happy to see that
now is still the nice girl that we all
know and we just hope that we won't see
this dragon again it's too scary the
songs if you watch the first movie you
know that Ben clearly paid homage to his
parents by singing the new version of be
our guest he had a cute accent when he
was trying to speak French
his parents dance like any parents
do and he updated the song so would
still sound great in 2015 now we clearly
understand my mouth fell in love with
the king of auradon but you might be
surprised to know that this is not the
only famous song you heard in the movie
in descendants - he'll describe his
father by saying that he's quick slick
and his neck is incredibly thick if that
sounds familiar that's because these are
the lyrics of the song that he's saying
in Beauty and the Beast but there is
another song that you probably didn't
recognize at the end of the movie we
understand why you were two shots when
uma stole been away from now but the
song they danced to was actually a remix
of kiss the girl from The Little Mermaid
it looks like uma just wanted to be just
like her mother and take the place of
the girl who was loved when we know that
it makes this seem much more meaningful
and we are happy when we think that this
kiss would have meant nothing anyway
because it was not true love the outfits
the most obvious way to know who were
the characters was simply to look at
their outfits for example mal was
dressed in purple jay wore red eb was
dressed in blue and Carlos were black
and white just like their parents did
and we could clearly see that the Evil
Queen's daughter and Cruella De Vil son
knew how to look good their look might
be more adapted to the 21st century but
it was still easy to know where they
came from and the same thing happens in
auradon
then more yellow and blue just like his
parents dick and Beauty and the Beast
and the fairy godmother and her daughter
Jane were always wearing the same colors
then there was Harry who always carried
around his father's hook and Lonnie who
let her Chinese heritage shine through
her clothes but there are also some
little details that you might have
missed Jai almost always wore Cobra
which was his father's favorite animal
uma also wore her mother's necklace that
looked just like a seashell
and then there was Evie who is just
obsessed with crowns and hearts are
there any other Disney connections that
we missed don't be shy to tell us what
it is in the comment section down below
we love to hear what you think and
that's it pretend Disney connection
that will make your jaw drop for more
stories like this make sure you watch 10
descendants characters reimagines in the
loud house thanks for watching
[Music]